There are many examples of how the media misrepresents studies. For example,
here are some recent headlines based on a real scientific study. Husbands who
do more housework may have less sex. Want to have more sex? Men stop doing
chores. Men not doing chores. Having a lot of sex. These media headlines are
based on a correlational study that measures the time and type of chores,
masculine and feminine and the amount of sexual encounters. In this study, they
found that couples who split the type of household chore, masculine versus
feminine reported five sexual encounters per month. However, when men completed
approximately 17 hours of masculine type chores and women completed
approximately 35 hours of feminine type chores they had nearly two more sexual
encounters per month. Chores or types of chores, masculine versus feminine. And
sexual encounters in this example. A variable is any characteristic that can
vary across individuals or across time within the same individuals. And this is
a correlational study. Because we are not manipulating any variables. Instead
we are just simply observing a mathematical relationship between two variables.
In this case chores, the number and type, masculine versus feminine and the
amount of sexual encounters. An important distinction in correlational studies
is that they do not manipulate any variables. Instead we're just measuring to
see whether the variables are related. This differs from experimental studies,
wherein researchers actually manipulated independent variable; and measure the
effect on the dependent variable. We will cover these types of studies, after
looking at correlations.